journée au fonds de solidarité de la ftq
le pdg du fonds yvon bolduc quitte ses
fonctions
les liens du fond avec certains membres
du crime organisé démontrer à la
commission charbonneau ont fait mal et
pour la première fois le fonds de
solidarité aura un président du conseil
d'administration qui n'est pas de la ftq
catherine kovacs
que le fonds appartient à ses 610 mais
l'actionnaire et c'est ça qui doit nous
guider le fonds de solidarité n'avait
plus le choix il fallait faire le ménage
à la suite des révélations à la
commission charbonneau un comité mis sur
pied en novembre dernier on est donc
arrivé à une série de recommandations
d'abord le président du conseil
d'administration du fonds doit être
indépendant le fonds n'a pas attendu et
a nommé l'administrateur robert parizeau
à sa tête le frère de jacques parizeau
le fonds de solidarité est une grande
institution
et puis les membres du conseil
d'administration passe de 17 à 19 se
nommer par la ftq passe de 10 à 7 les
administrateurs indépendants de 4 à 7 et
ceux élus par les actionnaires de 2 à 4
ces changements doivent encore être
approuvé par le gouvernement le
président de la ftq enjoint les
parlementaires à coopérer un changement
de gouvernance assez comme un nouveau
départ un nouveau départ mais aussi un
nouveau leadership au front de
solidarité dans la foulée des
changements yvon bolduc l'actuel pdg du
fonds est remercié je pense que c'était
inévitable si on voulait se redonner un
élan dans le but d'appliquer cette
nouvelle gouvernance lors les réactions
à ces recommandations n'ont pas tardé le
ministre des finances du québec nicolas
marceau annonce qu'il déposera un projet
de loi pour modifier la loi régissant le
fonds de solidarité
le parti libéral demeure sur sa faim
elle efface pas le passé et restera car
beaucoup de questions à poser la caq
crois que les changements proposés
assureront un nouveau départ pour le
fond tandis que québec solidaire
souhaite que le fonds ne se comporte pas
comme une banque les attentes des
québécois c'est le fonds de solidarité
ça se voit pas comme une des banques que
les dirigeants de fonds solidaire ess
comporte pas avec le fonds comme des
banquiers font avec des épargnes des
québécois
nouveau président de la ftq daniel boyer
qui a critiqué ouvertement l'acharnement
de la commission charbonneau sur la
centrale promet que dorénavant il va
collaborer entièrement avec la
commission dans un souci de transparence
catherine kovacs radio canada montréal